hello out everybody it's uh it's been a
minute Lewis the alcoholic back with one
more episode
of me and my shenanigans
well
a hard time trying to figure out what I
was going to talk about today because I
have so much to talk about because I
haven't been here you know since wow
and somebody asked me a couple questions
the other day and he says
who are you and you know where have you
been you know and uh what can you do and
where are you going
you know and I think that first one kind
of woke me up amongst all of them who am
I who am I that was a real serious
question and asked myself when I sat in
my room the other day all by myself
I said Louis who are you
and I thought back on the things that
happened in my life and what's going on
now
and
I am
I have created I mean this alcohol as a
pet created them I have created a
monster
I mean when I sat back because now right
now I'm I watch myself doing the shows I
never watched them before and I see I
see a side of me that I talk about but
I've never had I actually saw it when I
see it and I'm like wow so I think about
the kid I used to be back long time ago
uh
even with that being said today I'm
going to talk about I'm I'm gonna own it
I'm gonna own all this [__] I like to
say you it was your fault it was your
fault oh it was your fault and your yeah
no no no I'm gonna talk about my fault
all this [__] all of it's my fault any
kind of way it goes he's kind of with
Cosmo spin it's my fault so I have to I
have to accept that today I'm accepting
that you know what
when I was
um when I was five years old
I was told what my destiny probably
would be and what happened was we went
to a Kindergarten class and the teacher
had us take this piece of paper and we
would take a paintbrush and whatever we
thought in our mind we would write it
down on this piece of paper and I wrote
down I was crazy about trains you know
Lionel trains locomotives and Santa Fe
rails and all that so I drew this big
giant train on on the board and I was
trying to sit there and figure what can
I put in here you know I put s on one
side I put the S on the other side I put
a o in the middle
so I remember when the teachers walking
around you know talking about what all
the kids and what they meant she said
hold on she stopped the whole crash when
she saw my eyes oh [__] I'm looking
around she's okay class look at what
Donald look what he wrote look what he
wrote anybody can anybody tell me what
he wrote you know SOS what it was
one kid said
he need help the other kid said
he's gonna be a Soul Saver
right there it was it was a choice for
me to take it easy either Road of course
I took the wrong one the negative one I
need help so from that day on I always
thought I needed help
I never they had the balls not to ask
for it but I always did I was needed and
uh
through the third one in my life the
drugs now I'm gonna talk I'm gonna talk
about
howdy uh how dark it is see when when
you say is for you people when it gets
dark
the lights go out when it gets dark the
Moon is shining there's no light but
with us with an alcoholic with a drug
addict
we we we we invented a whole another a
whole nother shade of black our black is
so black it's so dark
try to
try to figure out
oh I see everybody in life I see life is
revolving everything is going around and
around and around and I see all this
stuff happening and everybody's like the
whole the whole world is moving forward
and see what alcoholic some people move
forward some people stay in one steal
and some people move backwards with an
alcoholic we don't know where the hell
we be going yeah so that's that's one
thought and itself that makes you wonder
about about yourself but as I asked that
I got to ask that question who am I
this is what I came up with
I'm a liar I'm a cheat and I'm a thief
I'm a manipulator all I know how to do
is lie everything in my subconscious
whatever conscious mind is all negative
but try to be able to try to have that
to accept that within your show and try
to try to make a make a life out of it
try to try to exist in a world to
compare to me to alcoholic the world the
whole world is a is a it's confusing you
know it's it's it's degrading it's it's
humiliating and all these kind of things
and and I have some kind of way I figure
some kind of way I figured out how to
how to how to survive through that how
to manipulate the system to get into
that some kind of way
so I was thinking well
why am I so why am I so why why can't I
let go of this this anger frustration
and bewilderment and and why do I have
to suffer like I do I just suffer and
suffer and suffer and enter everything
and inside inside of me
some people say the whole they say
pressure can bust a pipe with the
pressure with me and my alcoholism
it's so it's so it's so I don't know
what the word is but it's it's so it's
it's oppressing and it holds me down so
every time every time
a product for example every time I
relapse when I first went to my first
rehab I was about
22 years old and the first time I
relapsed from that time on until now
I like to tell y'all I got a little time
sober I'm doing better now same old
[__] same old [__] same old [__]
just a different song
so
I am
I've got to the point where I just I
just I'm just gonna start getting on the
spot you know and uh
I don't think that there's no help for
me matter of fact me myself not just
mine no that there ain't no hope for me
but even in all my darkest winning
alcohol with all of my darkest see every
group we want
if you when I'm when I'm sober if I'm so
for a day or half a day whatever
my mind can kind of you know kind of put
some put things together but when I let
me take one [__] drink if I take one
one [__] drink then the person sit
over here that used to look like a woman
or a man I don't know when they wanna
take a drink or hit I don't give a [__]
I'm gonna do what I do anyway on the
other side if this person over here is
doing me wrong or if this person is
being good to me am I gonna [__] them
over you know
I saw my grandmother cry
when I went into her purse
and I took some money from my
grandmother I think that's the first
time I really realized that how powerful
this is where I'm going to get is how
powerless I am because
I saw her and I still remember her that
day on these days around eastern time
and I remember her calling my dad and
saying your son has a real real bad
problem
I like to tell you guys most time I like
to blame it on that no with that because
my you see nobody I don't like to tell
people that I saw my dad cry then when I
took my grandmother's money and he came
over to my grandma's house he sat beside
me on the bed and he cried I saw my
daddy my father broke down I never seen
my father that I mean he teaches he just
broke down and cry he says my fault and
I felt so shitty because I feel like
yeah [__] is your goddamn fault
but at the same time I'm thinking you
know I gotta take some responsibility
because he ain't put no pipe in my hand
he ain't putting no alcohol at the
bottom of my hand I did me going through
the disgusting life of mine you know I
was I was to the point where this is a
trick thing about me because I wanted to
die man I just wanted to die I mean
I wanted to die I hate living I hated
being here
and um
but where I'm going with this
when I came here sat down in this chair
I guess it was about four or five years
ago
somebody told me to come in here and lie
about something that happened to me so
my indication I was going to come in and
lie about every [__] thing I'm a good
liar anyway that's all I do is I can lie
to a damn note especially when I'm
reading I want to hear [__] I came in
here
kill me and I talked about that time
when I was molested
I think that time and the time about my
daughter getting took me those are two
things that really really really were
really causing me a lot of pain and they
still do to this day but once I started
to talk about that when I said writer
started to talk about that this is where
I started to release the freshman so the
person was still there the person was
still on and then to one side it was it
was getting worse but it was getting
better because I was releasing that
pressure you know so then I came
to a point where
I felt a little better but I still
didn't I still I still didn't have them
so where I'm going with this is
and find out who I am if I want to
answer the question I'm the drug addict
and I'll call everything all these other
bad things but there's another side of
me too I never talked about him either
but this guy
he's quiet he don't say too much you
know my help with people and he just
he's like a pushover [__] or a punk
[__] you just push push him over
uh I'd like to talk about him I like to
talk about the worst and the worst and
worse
so going back to where it was dark
I've walked down some streets
and I've seen the devil behind me
and the devil said man what that where
the hell are you going I ain't going
down that [__] I've sat in some
places I've sat in some crack houses
I've sat in a crack house one time here
was the lady over here she was
22 there was a 12 year old daughter on
that side and I'm trying to figure out
how I can I can [__] both of them and if
I said I did it both of them on the
instruments of alcohol
here I I I I I I
God I took all my money man all the
money that I made everything I ever done
I was sitting there trying to figure out
how much money I spent maybe or maybe
over a million dollars or whatever it's
even on drugs and alcohol you know and
and how I made it this far but that's
just all that's all I've been doing so
I've ever done it's been all my money
all my money
all my money so I give all my money to
this
entity
some people call it the white girl you
know the white girl she's
just tall she's got big chests like that
she got big legs like that she's got a
big old wire like that in between her
legs and she can get busy when she want
to get busy [__] don't even exist
you can't see her
but I have to I have to I have to uh
emit glass in hand and pipe in hand
anymore I can't I can't worry about am I
gonna be an addict anymore I can't worry
about him I'm gonna [__] somebody over
anymore whatever whatever if I I'm up in
here it's like whatever happens happens
you know whatever happens happens if I
get killed there's there's a guy after
me and if he sees me one day he's gonna
kill me it's no it's no it's no if
answer but he's going to kill me and I
need to worry about him all the time
what he was when he's walk up on me and
see me
you know
so the worry about about the the I mean
my mother always tell me she said don't
ever wait till it's too late do you
think feel like you know it's too
there's nothing I can do about it
because of my age but that's why I'm at
right now I'm like oh man I just turned
six years old you know and um
I'm gonna turn six years old
my family of somebody in my family
they're one person in my family that
heard me do one of my shows and they
kind of felt for me they had empathy for
me so he gave me this car and uh I
really didn't want it but I said well
I'll take the car I ain't got no job
he's riding thing most time the cards
that [__] is still
so right about the time where I started
bragging and getting biggie
on the 13th of November 11th of March my
birthday is on 11th of March
I walked in the house I have a problem
losing my keys oh I mean I've lost three
or four sets of keys to my apartment and
everything so I went to bed that night
and I got up in about four o'clock in
the morning and I said where the hell my
damn key well [__] I must have left me
in the car I ran downstairs ain't got
ain't no car down there ain't got no
keys no cars
and I'm sitting there I'm walking and
I'm walking around I'm walking around
downtown I never forget I'm thinking
about that kind of trotting Zone when it
was when there was nobody there with him
that's how I feel it's like as big as
his downtown is I didn't see nobody and
I had a something in my hand I had I had
to add some heat in my pocket and I'm
walking around with this heat and I I
don't know what I was going to do but I
was thinking the first [__] I
see it looked like he got in my car imma
blow his [__] hell I was there
I mean I was actually I was a lot of
times I talk [__] and I'm not going to
put people know me I'm not gonna be I'm
just talking a whole bunch of [__] I've
been on but this that District like I
was I was gonna [__] somebody up
and uh so I went over to the police
station and they said
I think they I walked I walked in this
movie station went to them with the heat
in my damn pocket I didn't give a [__] I
walked in I said hey
somebody stole my [__] car I wouldn't
want to wear my [__] car I had a
bottle of liquor over here because
I got the piss over here and he comes
hold on sit down you sit down right
there
sit down
they calm me down give me a glass of
water and everything so the thing is I
uh they they care they don't care they
don't care They Don't Care About Us they
don't care so I told the guy said it had
to be somebody in my ability because if
they took the if somebody because it's
always somebody in front of my building
sitting down but this particular night
they knew exactly when pull that key out
of my door walk down those stairs know
how to drive off with that car where
nobody could feel myself this
[__] had to know me so
you have Garwood so I tell the security
this place I say hey man somebody stole
my [__] car what what the [__] am I
doing the police have to come over here
they take us half a Conway and do sense
doesn't I go back to the police station
I said you better hope you find this
[__] before I do because if you
don't it's gonna be next day
I am one more time when you got that man
so I'm sitting there and I'm thinking is
it I don't have a damn thing in life I
don't have no no no I don't got no TVs I
ain't got nothing tonight I have my
deodorant I used to use on one side
because I got to save for the whole week
because I can't use because I gotta say
one day so and now they took my little
car my little debit card that I had my
food shampoo that was all my food stamps
they all of us don't
about the other day
are you called a friend of mine and said
wait tell Mr Banks we we got a car
okay so the last time I got you know I
went to pick it up and
I didn't have any money and I felt like
I'm bullshitting because I actually I
stood outside the yard
and I actually talked my way into
getting enough money to pull that thing
out of that out of that impound you know
then I got it back and it it they messed
up they messed up being something but
I'm thinking where I'm going with is why
is it that it's like all bad luck
everything that happens to me is like
bad luck you know it's like it's like
you know I I I'm so bad my I'm six years
old my brain is getting forgetful man I
get up in the morning and I got I got I
got I got to see I got the coffee cup in
my hand and I'm going to the box to get
this sugar I can't remember what I I
can't remember which way I'm going
where's the coffee cup my room is so
small I mean if you mean you walk in the
room together we have to go around each
other you're in the smallest room it's
only me every morning I get up I can't
find one shoe I can't never I can't
never find my watch I can't even find my
comb to comb my hair I got 10 hats in
there and I like to put my hats on
that's what I have on I never I can
never do it because I can never find the
hat that I want to use it today before
I know so they wanted to put me in a a
study a friend of mine he's a
professional he go works for the doctors
and he puts you in these uh lab studies
where they catch you at the guinea pig
or whatever so he takes me down and he
said okay we're gonna put it in one foot
let's get schizophrenia I ain't got no
damn schizophrenia I go down in the
doctor's diagnosing me he looks at me
he's you've been doing those damn before
no not really well come with me I said
oh [__]
so they take you by the do these
diagnosis and they had schizophrenia and
some other [__] they claim that I had
and I'm in denial I'm in denial
I don't have none of this stuff but you
know what like I said I'm owning my [__]
today I have a little schizophrenia um
um I have a couple of minimal problems
uh I'm starting to
not only am I forgetting a lot of um
I'm not caring as much uh I don't take
baths every day like I used to I take
baths maybe once or twice a week you
know I just I just it's I don't I don't
care I I just for certainly I just don't
give a [__]
I don't care
so anyway I was trying to figure out
from the question the guy asked me about
who I was this is who I become
this idiot this imbecile this low life
just boundaries just just a big ball or
nothing Cabot confusion that got thrown
into the middle of nowhere and created
everything out of nothing and still end
up nothing and going back to him going
nowhere to nowhere fast so I thought
back about why in the [__]
and this is what the question I asked I
asked myself and whatever entity was out
there I said what in the hell I'm
sitting in the wall by myself
that's when I got real like all by
myself I said yeah I did this [__] with
the little girls yes I did the [__] at
the homosexual just suck my dick for the
money yes I stole this yes I did that
yes I did it all
so why in there so obviously I don't
know what the [__] I'm doing here I
don't know why I'm here I have no idea
somebody asked me what my origin was why
origin what the [__] origin orange is
the crack of the dope house and the
goddamn liquor store that's why I always
end up now that's why it's dark it
started there so why am I here
I mean what what why why why did you
grade me so this is the thought that
came up in my mind you know I'm kind of
I'm a little off anyway
acid
everything that is created was created
and when it was made it was manufactured
by somebody and it was put out before it
got put out on the market he got tried
they got tested and they got put on and
while and and when he got put on the
market they put a a piece of paper
instructions on it on how to use it how
to use it properly exactly if you don't
use it that way
possible for my screw up I was put
somewhere I was made by some kind of
manufacturer I was put here to do
something
something I just can't figure out what
it is because I failed at everything I'm
big I'm big dummy big dumb [__] stupid
[__] dude
even through all that Darkness even as
dark as it gets for the owl corner to
get in half there was a little little
light and I said Bing I thought about
soft white underbelly and I was a matter
of fact I was I was walking through a uh
uh or like a like a little Mars
panhandles just on a mall uh on west
side of town the other night took a
couple of weeks ago and this couple
comes in the store they're probably
watch it live and they were like
Lewis yeah Lewis yeah so I said wait a
minute sir ma'am
where do you know me from this well we
know you're from YouTube I said what you
know so I walked off and I walked and I
was at in my in my [__] I just out of
curiosity what do you know because I
asked him excuse me I said why are you
what do you what is it you like about me
talking on on for YouTube
and I said well you just have a unique
way of telling your story whatever so
now that's one just yesterday there was
a lady
across the street from where I was where
I stayed and she said hey Lewis what's
up
I said okay I know where you know me
from I said well I said what what do you
know me from how do you what so she said
that I talk about how dark it is he said
I never knew how dark it gets for you
guys and when I hear you telling the
story I can realize I could kind of I'm
kind of there about how dark it is and
so I thought about I said well when I
come here today I could I would talk to
you about how dark it is the dark things
that you know
to be able to talk about it
is more phenomenal than anything to me
because when I looked at myself on it
internet
I liked what I saw I couldn't I was like
oh I said that I said that you're damn
right I said it you know I like I like
the people to come to me and say every
now and I get a guy that goes hey hey
Lewis what the hell is wrong with you
man you you're gonna talk about that
kind of stuff for you man you're telling
all your business yeah well I said to
this guy I bet you listening now why do
you keep turning me on see those are the
kind of people I'm going for it those
are the kind of people that I like to
talk to the people who have been through
the same thing the people the people who
who let me tell you what I did one time
put some Humanity
ah ah [__] Omar so every time I'm going
to get some crack
if I'm not by the restroom I'm gonna
[__] on myself I'm not I'm I'm [__]
right there where I'm at you know if I'm
in the church if I'm in school if I'm on
the street I'm gonna take a [__] right
there where I'm at I am not [__] I'm
so I'm sitting in [__]
and I'm walking to where I'm going I go
get my rocks I sit down on the curb or
wherever I'm sitting in somebody's house
sometime in nice people's nice houses
and I have to can I use reversal they
don't let me go to the restroom I see it
right there I'm sitting up in people's
houses [__] and feces all running down
my legs that's how when I when I'm when
I take a hit when I take a drink
I can't see none of it I can't smell
none of it
I woke up in the in the not in the bed I
woke up in a
in a cubicle box out on the beach I
don't know how the [__] I got there when
the hell they put me there I woke up the
lady was so [__] ugly when I turned
around and looked at I said God what the
hell and she turned around and looked at
me and smiled with no damn piece it
didn't hurt to do it I said tell me I
said oh God tell me these are the kind
of things that happened I was in the I
was I was I was uh I held hostage one
time uh I met a guy and he was uh I
think he was homosexual he was gonna try
to take me and take me somewhere to to
do his his whatever he was going to do
so when he got me over there it was
great big it was like a like a a
warehouse and he had all these different
cars and these like different stages
with these like like tits in one place I
think he was running a pornography ring
back there whatever but he put out he
put out a
um whatever that little sword and
he was going into this room he was
raping this woman and he wanted me to go
in there and to
to participate with him in his rape
and I was so scared and he said let me
give you something
to make you feel a little better that
maybe you could participate in his head
with me man I ain't gonna never came up
with this big old yellow ball it was a
big old bottle of crack now I hit that
crack but when I had a crackpot There's
No Remorse there's no shame that you
don't you don't you don't care about
nothing
here I am and where is it with this girl
and this girl will screaming for your
life
and I'm holding it down he's banging
from the back I'm turning around going
to the front we're doing all this [__]
all of a sudden I got real real real
paranoid I mean when you parallel crack
you'd be so [__] paranoid you think
that if I walk down the street I think
that I don't know that the devil's going
to come jump out of the bushes to give
me some of the wheels are gonna fall
it's gonna be earthquake this particular
night I didn't care I this guy this guy
was gonna kill me um
yeah he was gonna kill me uh because I'd
seen his Enterprise whatever he's doing
he was stealing cars and doing cars and
he was raping women and making taking
underage women and making them do
my sister so uh now I'm assistant right
because I'm there with him and I did it
with him four days ago
said I would never have you done anyway
to that channel I jumped I did I jumped
through a window like what about this
side I jumped through the window and I
still got a couple cuts on me and when I
landed the blood was was rushing and
running out of my body and I couldn't go
get the police here and ask you what
happened so Under the Influence for
about a week
I stayed like that I didn't I didn't
take I didn't take a shower I didn't
wipe myself I was I guess I was walking
down the street looking like a bloody
mary or some [__] I was [__] up those
these kind of things
and I
one of the issues when I saw my daughter
and she was a
I saw my daughter Shake
I never had to talk about him I saw my
baby [__]
she was about
I don't know one one and a half two
years old when I saw I saw where the
convulsion when that damn crack okay
how can you do that little baby like
that look at that little innocent little
baby you brought into the world and
you're so sorry so stupid so what is
this they look at us shaking you can't
do a damn thing about it so what's the
first thing you think I went there I
went and got another hit and went and
got another bottle of liquor
I died I was telling somebody that I
when I when when they took my they took
my daughter from me I died I got I was
already I'd already given up I died I
gave up on it any kind of way I just
gave up I gave him one
but as the scenario goes around
I got you the two I'm I'm gonna have to
dilemma right now I got two choices
now where I was going ever since I sat
down in this chair
I found I I found some purpose for me
this is I have a perfect when I come
here this is the only place that I come
that I won't I won't take a drink I
never think about drinking I never think
about drugging I do this sober because
when I come here I I'm I'm keeping it
real as we say I'm keeping it real so
what I was thinking
this little voice of whatever told me
maybe that's my purpose to share my
experience and what happened to me that
it may touch another human being and the
ones that come to me and tell me that
most oh man everybody comes and told me
they tell me I touch them in some kind
of way be it negative or positive but
the ones that the ones that it that it
that hits in the negative way the ones
that hurt the ones that want to beat me
because of what I said those are the
kind of people that I want to talk to
because if I you know if I'm sitting
here and I'm throwing if I'm throwing
rocks I'm throwing bricks you know if
it's a crowd of people out there
wherever it's gonna hit the only way
it's gonna stay out so that's where I'm
at because if if I had never sat down in
this chair
a guy had a gun in my head told me to
break yourself [__] I don't [__] you
[__] you're gonna shoot shooting
you guys doing push him away from my
push him away so anyway
so and and that and saying all that um
I'm going to use what I have use what I
have to give and give it to everybody
else now it's now the whole world knows
me the whole world knows all my [__] so
if this if I ever want to get married
you know they say I didn't know that
about you if you watch YouTube it's all
out here when I came here I pulled my
drawers down now you know I got a hairy
ass and a big old dick because then when
I came in here I put my charger and
showed you I showed you my ass and
everything so that was the reason why I
did that is because
I am getting some some some closure in
identify identification on who I really
am because I am that I'm all that
negative kind of [__] right now I want
to take all that negative [__] put in a
big ball and create some positive out of
it and hope that I could use you guys
along with me and that's where I'm at
right now so until the next time I see
you in Lewis and I'm out all right thank
you Lewis